welcome to an exciting exploration of
The Cutting Edge world of modern
agriculture where technology meets
tradition to create a revolution in
farming today we're diving deep into the
extraordinary capabilities of the
world's most expensive and advanced
agricultural Machinery designed to
redefine how we cultivate and harvest
crops these state-of-the-art machines
are not just tools they are marvels of
innovation engineered to increase
efficiency productivity and
sustainability on a scale never seen
before as we journey through this
fascinating realm you'll discover how
these powerful machines are transforming
the landscape of farming making it more
precise efficient and ultimately more
profitable join us as we uncover the
future of Agriculture where every
machine is a masterpiece of engineering
pushing the boundaries of what's
possible in farming
before starting this video please like
this video And subscribe to our Channel
first on our list is the moon of harvest
machine a true Marvel of agricultural
engineering this Advanced machine is
specifically designed to streamline the
Apple harvesting process utilizing
Precision rotating blades to carefully
cut apples from their
branches what sets it apart is its
ability to transport the harvested
apples directly into into its built-in
Processing Unit ensuring efficiency from
the field to the processing stage the
munov Harvest machine also features
adjustable cutting height and speed
allowing it to adapt seamlessly to
various terrains and Orchard
configurations making it an
indispensable tool for modern farming
next we have the TU blind retriever an
Innovative attachment for skid steer
loaders designed for efficient handling
of small s wear Bales equipped with a 10
bail grapple this tool ensures Swift and
secure bail management significantly
reducing the risk of leaf loss and
minimizing the occurrence of broken
Bales due to excessive handling it's
clever design makes it a valuable
addition to any farming operation
enhancing both productivity and
preservation of quality the strawberry
harvesting robot is a Cutting Edge
machine equipped with advanced sensors
and AI technology enabling it to
accurately identify and harvest only the
ripest
strawberries with its gentle yet precise
picking mechanism the robot ensures that
each strawberry is carefully handled to
preserve its quality once harvested the
strawberries are efficiently transported
to factories where they undergo
processing for packaging and Juice
production streamlining the farm to
factory process and ensuring fresh
produce reaches the market quickly the
kiwi fruit Harvester is a highly
Advanced machine that automates both the
harvesting and pollination of kiwi
fruits utilizing a sophisticated robot
programmed by skilled human operators
after the Kiwi fruits are carefully
harvested by the robot they are
transported to processing facilities
where they undergo sorting packaging and
preparation for
distribution this seamless integration
of Technology not only enhances
efficiency but also ensures that the
Kiwi fruits reach consumers in optimal
condition the Delroy mobile versatile
cauliflower Harvester is equipped with
dual cutting heads that expertly
separate cauliflower stocks from florids
with remarkable speed and precision
significantly boosting harvesting
efficiency on a similar note the compact
flower pot transport robot is designed
to navigate tight spaces effortlessly
ensuring the smooth and efficient
transport of flower pots across various
terrains both machines are perfect
examples of how advanced technology is
enhancing productivity and Precision in
agriculture making farming tasks more
streamlined and less labor
intensive the OB 100 Route picking
machine is a Powerhouse in the field
featuring a robust 20 3 PS engine and a
100 cm working with allowing it to
efficiently Harvest between 1,000 and
2,000 tons of root crops with ease in
contrast the rupa2 stands out as a two-
row potato Harvester equipped with a
substantial 7.5 ton bunker capacity
making it ideal for handling large
harvests both machines exemplify the
Pinnacle of agricultural efficiency
designed to maximize output while m
maintaining high standards of precision
and
reliability The Green Onion Harvester is
a remarkable machine that effortlessly
traverses vast Fields covering tens of
hectares and streamlining the onion
harvesting process its Advanced design
ensures that onion harvesting becomes a
breeze even across large scale
operations meanwhile the John Deere
6150r known for its efficient bail
loading capabilities and the John Deere
6620 renowned for its reliable bailing
performance are favored choices among
Hayfield operators together these
machines enhance productivity and
Effectiveness in both onion and hay
farming proving indispensable in modern
agricultural practices next we Spotlight
a powerful fruit Harvester designed to
collect over 300 kilobar fruit in a
single operation demonstrating
exceptional efficiency and productivity
in large-scale Fruit farming its
advanced technology ensures that each
Harvest is both Swift and effective
maximizing output with minimal effort
similarly the Tomato Harvester is
engineered to rapidly gather tomatoes
from the field while preserving their
quality reducing the risk of damage and
ensuring that the produce reaches its
destination in excellent condition both
machines represent significant advant
ANC Ms in agricultural technology
enhancing the speed and quality of
harvests did you know that only 5% of
cranberries are sold fresh the vast
majority are processed into sauces
juices dried fruit and various other
products reflecting their versatility
and the demand for processed cranberry
Goods in processing facilities the
semi-automatic Citrus peeler plays a
crucial role by efficiently preparing
citrus fruits for further processing its
Advanced design ensures a streamlined
and precise peel removal process which
is essential for maintaining High
productivity and quality in citrus fruit
processing the carrot Harvester is
engineered with specialized blades and
Conveyor Systems that effectively lift
carrots from the soil significantly
accelerating the harvesting process its
innovative design not only boosts
efficiency but also ensures that carrots
are handled with care to maintain
Quality Moving On from the fields let's
explore the fascinating journey of
chicks after they hatch from their eggs
this critical stage in their development
involves several key steps including
Immediate Care nutrition and growth
phases which are essential for their
transition from hatchlings to healthy
mature Birds big shout out to these
incredible machines that make farming a
breeze
on a scale of 1 to awesome how many
points would you give these machines
make sure to like this video And
subscribe to our channel the btr3 Brower
KSM grass cutter represents the
Forefront of agricultural Innovation
designed to automate and streamline the
grass harvesting process with remarkable
precision and efficiency its advanced
technology enables quick and consistent
cutting making it a valuable asset for
large scale grass operations meanwhile
the modern bell pepper Harvester is
engineered to efficiently gather bell
peppers from the field ensuring optimal
yield and quality for subsequent Factory
processing both machines exemplify the
latest advancements in agricultural
technology enhancing productivity and
Effectiveness in their respective
Fields The Onion processing line is a
comprehensive system that meticulously
prepares onions for Market by washing
peeling sorting and packaging them
ensuring that each onion meets high
standards of quality and freshness in a
different realm unmanned aerial vehicles
uavs have revolutionized agricultural
practices by providing efficient and
precise pesticide spraying significantly
reducing the need for manual labor while
ensuring thorough coverage of crops
these technological advancements
exemplify how Automation and Innovation
are enhancing productivity and
Effectiveness in modern
agriculture have you seen this
state-of-the-art motorized machine it
swiftly prunes branches and leaves from
trees completing the task in just
minutes with remarkable
efficiency similarly the tulip bulb
Harvester is designed to cut and
retrieve tulip bulbs from the ground
with precision and speed meanwhile in
this vibrant Papaya Garden diligent
farmers are harvesting exceptionally
impressive fruits showcasing their skill
and dedication to highquality produce
for Farmers a tree planting machine like
this is an indispensable tool making the
process of planting trees more efficient
and less labor intensive during this
year's wheat Harvest an unfortunate fire
did occur but but fortunately there were
no injuries or loss of equipment
allowing the Harvest to continue without
significant disruption such advancements
in technology are crucial for ensuring
that farming operations run smoothly
even in challenging
circumstances ever wondered why tulip
flowers are selectively harvested beyond
their ornamental value they are also
utilized as food ingredients and
medicinal herbs adding to their
versatility
meanwhile this Advanced robot equipped
with GPS and lar sensors autonomously
navigates Fields with Precision
seamlessly traversing rows and
automatically turning to the next row
for Effective weed
elimination its technology not only
enhances efficiency but also ensures
that fields are maintained with minimal
manual
labor the egg breaking machine is a
Powerhouse for large scale operations
designed to handle High volumes of eggs
with remarkable efficiency and speed
similarly the soil digging machine plays
a crucial role in preparing land for
planting by thoroughly breaking up and
conditioning the soil after the
watermelon Harvest these fruits undergo
a thorough cleaning process to achieve a
glossy rind enhancing their appearance
and ensuring they are Market ready after
mangoes are harvested and brought to the
factory they undergo a detailed
processing sequence that includes
sorting washing and packaging to prepare
them for distribution meanwhile the c485
lawn mower stands out with its powerful
engine and precision cutting blades
delivering quick and efficient mowing
for large areas this combination of
advanced technology and meticulous
processing ensures both optimal fruit
quality and well-maintained
Landscapes the cable car efficiently
transports large quantities of
agricultural produce at a speed of 90 m
per minute ensuring Swift and secure
delivery from farms to processing
facilities meanwhile the sheep shearing
robot employs GPS and AI technology to
autonomously Monitor and guide the flock
performing precise shearing with minimal
human
intervention these Innovations enhance
both the logistics of produce handling
and the efficiency of livestock
management let's observe Colombian
Farmers as they Pick and Pack sweet corn
directly in the field ensuring the
produce is fresh and Market ready
meanwhile in the US dairy cows
consistently produce more than 7.12
gallons of milk per day thanks to
Advanced and efficient Machinery that
supports High milk yields these
practices highlight the effectiveness of
modern agricultural techniques
in enhancing both crop and dairy
production meet the chicken catching
machine the essential tool on poultry
Farms that ensures the smooth and
efficient transportation of chickens to
their next
destination this machine streamlines
operations reducing labor and stress for
both the birds and Farm Workers on the
crop side the robust plowing machine
equipped with 10 plow shares
effortlessly prepares Fields by
thoroughly breaking up the soil ensuring
optimal conditions for planting and
maximizing crop yields these remarkable
machines are truly redefining the
boundaries of agricultural technology
showcasing unprecedented levels of
efficiency precision and productivity in
the field from harvesting and planting
to processing and livestock management
each Innovation plays a crucial role in
transforming the way we Farm making
agriculture more sust sustainable and
effective than ever before your
continued support enables us to keep
bringing you the latest developments in
this rapidly evolving sector helping
farmers and Industry professionals stay
ahead of the curve we are grateful for
your trust and commitment as we explore
and share The Cutting Edge advancements
shaping the future of farming thank you
for being part of this exciting Journey
make sure to like this video And
subscribe to our Channel and please hit
the Bell